foreign
[Music]
South Africa one of the most unequal
countries in the world the richest
one-tenth of one percent owns almost 30
percent of all the country's wealth more
than double what the bottom 90 percent
owns income and wealth inequality are
not new in fact economists and
historians who've charted economic
inequality throughout history haven't
found a single Society without it which
raises a bleak question is inequality
inevitable one way to estimate
inequality is with a number called the
genie index which is calculated by
comparing the income or wealth
distribution of a perfectly equal
Society to the actual income or wealth
distribution the area of this shape
multiplied by two is the genie index a
genie of one indicates perfect
inequality one person has everything and
everyone else has nothing you'd never
see this in real life because everyone
except that one person would starve a
genie index of zero and indicates
perfect equality everyone has exactly
the same income or wealth but you also
never see this in real life not even in
communist countries because for one
thing that would mean paying everyone no
matter how young old what job they're in
or where they work the exact same wage
typical after-tax Genies in developed
countries today are around 0.3 so
there's a wide range from pretty equal
to pretty unequal before we go any
further you should know what the genie
index or any other measure of economic
inequality doesn't tell us it gives no
information about how income and wealth
are distributed across genders races
educational backgrounds or other
demographics it doesn't tell us how easy
or difficult it is to escape poverty and
it also gives no insight as to how a
particular society arrived at its
present level of inequality
economic inequality is deeply entangled
with other types of inequality for
example generations of discrimination
imperialism and colonialism create a
deeply rooted power and class
inequalities that persist to this day
but we still need at least a rough
measure of who gets how much in a
country that's what the genie index
gives us some countries are economically
much more unequal than others and that's
because a significant portion of
economic inequality is the result of
choices that governments make let's talk
about some of these choices first what
kind of economy to use
in the 20th century some countries
switched to Socialism or communism for a
variety of reasons including reducing
economic inequality these changes did
dramatically reduce economic inequality
in the two largest non-capitalist
economies China and the Soviet Union
especially in the Soviet Union but
neither country prospered as much as the
world's leading economies so yes people
earned about as much as their neighbors
did but that wasn't very much
this and many other issues contributed
to the Soviet Union's collapse in 1991
and China to grow more quickly shifted
its economy towards capitalism starting
in the late 1970s what about capitalist
countries can they choose to reduce
economic inequality it's tempting to
think no because the whole point of
capitalism is to hold enough gold coins
to be able to dive into them like
Scrooge McDuck
China seems to provide the textbook
example of this after it became more
capitalist its Genie index shot up from
under 0.4 to over 0.55 meanwhile it's
per capita yearly income jumped from the
rough equivalent of fifteen hundred
dollars to over thirteen thousand
dollars but there are many counter
examples capitalist countries in which
inequality is actually holding steady or
decreasing France has kept its Genie
index below 0.32 since 1979. Ireland's
Genie has been trending mostly downwards
since 1995. the Netherlands and Denmark
have kept theirs below 0.28 since the
1980s how do they do it one way is with
taxes personal income taxes in most
countries are progressive the more money
you make the higher your tax rate and
the more Progressive your tax system the
more it reduces inequality so for
example while pre-tax income inequality
in France is roughly the same as it is
in the U.S post-tax inequality in France
is roughly 20 percent lower meanwhile
inheritance taxes can reduce the amount
of wealth that a single family can amass
over Generations Germany and many other
European countries have inheritance or
estate taxes that kick in at a few
thousand to a few hundred thousand Euros
depending on who's inheriting the US on
the other hand lets you inherit 12
million dollars without paying any
federal tax
another way is with transfers when the
government takes tax revenues from one
group of people and gives it to another
for example Social Security Programs tax
people who work and use the revenue to
support retirees in Italy about a
quarter of Italians disposable household
income comes from government transfers
that's a lot especially relative to the
us where the figure is just over five
percent
Third Way is to ensure that everyone has
access to things like education and
Health Care a highly educated healthy
Workforce can command a higher salary on
the market thus reducing inequality
a fourth way is addressing the digital
divide the gap between those who have
access to the internet and those who do
not
fifth way is dealing with extreme wealth
multi-billionaires can buy social media
platforms news outlets policy think
tanks perhaps even politicians and bend
them to their will threatening the very
fabric of democracy now we are just
barely scratching the surface of
inequality here we haven't touched on
the DraStic divides in who has wealth
and who doesn't the power structures
that prevent social and economic
mobility and the DraStic inequality
between countries the fact that for
example just three Americans have 90
billion more dollars than Egypt a
country of a hundred million people
and here's one final thing to think
about power and wealth are
self-reinforcing which means that
equality is not left to their own
devices societies tend toward inequality
unless we weaken the feedback loops of
wealth and power concentration
[Music]
but will capitalism allow for these
kinds of adjustments or is it
fundamentally broken explore the answer
to this question with this video or
continue to expand your understanding of
Economics on the world economic forum's
YouTube channel
thank you